[Applause]
shirley came to us with her husband
gordon
married couple we just feel so
so privileged and honored to look after
them
she lost her husband in december
she got covered in march
[Music]
when covey got into home i think it
destroyed it
there's nobody else here
[Music]
this is the story of a care home and its
fight with covid19
i knew deep down in the hearts of hearts
if nothing changed
we wouldn't survive when the worst
of the pandemic did pass the home became
very quiet
it's the story of what happened after
the peak had passed
told by the carers and residents who
went through it
after everything that we've been through
we just thought it won't come to this
we've gone from hero to zero within a
matter of months
[Music]
but it's also a story about broken
political promises
i don't want the brought up in the
country where the only way pensioners
can get long-term care
is by selling their home security in old
age
we're determined to do the right thing
by these people older people
will not have to worry we will fix
the crisis in social care once
this is just horrific this is the worst
thing i've ever been through in my life
i'm so emotional about this
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i know
the first case of covert 19 enters
newfield
in early march you could see the pure
fear on people's faces including my own
i mean when it started happening i was
fearful to go to work every day
and not knowing what's going to happen
to you know the residents the families
ourselves and our families
it was a very difficult time will you
ever forget it
never i will never forget that time
newfield care home
quickly finds itself engulfed by covid
one case leads to two then six
then ten and before they know it the
most
vulnerable are infected
okay all right all right
we're used to dealing with death as
awful as it is
it's the worst part of our job but not
as much
not as much
and this is when i first met shirley
scott she's 84
and she suffered from parkinson's for
the last 25
years she's tested positive for covid19
and at her age this is really serious
has it been a tough couple of days
because your family used to come visit
all the time didn't they now
she's such a strong strong strong leader
and i think
she's such an inspiration
[Music]
covid is about to bring new field to its
knees
it'll kill the residents first then it
will infect the business
because to understand the impact of
covid you need to understand
what keeps care homes running how
they're funded who pays
and how much over 90 percent of our
residents generally receive funding from
from the government be it
local authority or or health ultimately
so
we can't dictate what fee we charge we
are told by
local authorities what we're getting
paid the amount councils pay varies
a lot from place to place sheffield pays
647 pounds per person per week
the second lowest of all local
authorities in england
a fee they say is in line with
neighboring councils
20 miles west in derbyshire the council
there pays 783 pounds
that's 136 pounds a week more for the
same level of care
and these variations continue from
gateshead in the north to cornwall in
the south
so over the years we've seen an increase
in costs we've not seen an additional
increase in the fee that we get paid
that's sufficient to meet those
increasing costs it's just the maths
don't add up
funding is so important when it comes to
understanding the long-term
impact that coronavirus has had on our
care homes
when the nhs was formed in 1948 social
care wasn't put on the same footing
and that was a deliberate decision at
the time that was reflecting
life expectancy in the 1940s and the
fact that people
didn't live a very long time after
retirement
so what's that meant is we now have two
very different systems
overall the amount of money we spend on
social care is much less
than for the nhs this current year we're
spending
less than we spent in 2010 on social
care
we're still spending 400 million pounds
less than we did a decade ago
social care the system that looks after
our elderly residents
is now chronically underfunded and
year-on-year reductions in the amount of
money we're paying for care
has meant that a number of providers
have been in a really very fragile state
as we've moved into the 2020s
a very fragile state the last thing care
homes in a fragile state need right now
is a health care crisis that hits them
more than anyone else
so when the worst of the pandemic did
pass the home became very quiet
it's become very lifeless
i think we just thought things would
pick up things would get better
as well as having permanent residence
new field
also acts as an overflow for local
hospitals
the nhs buys bed space during busy times
it's a big contract but the nhs now says
it wants more people to be cared for in
their own homes
care homes are expensive and this
contract
will not be renewed it is a major blow
sort of availability
care home owners like nicola richards
now find themselves in deep financial
trouble
empty homes are bad for business and
newfield can't afford to sit empty for
very much
longer it's been under pressure for
years and this is pre-covered
and i've talked about this for many
years and ultimately
we need intervention we need financial
support from
either central government or local
government and it needs to happen now
but at the end of september with no
residence to care for
and no money coming in the home is put
up for sale
time has run out
we knew something was wrong when the
meeting was cold um
on the thursday morning that's when we
was told newfield was struggling at the
moment and we could potentially be
closing the unit
nobody could speak they didn't know what
to say everybody was shocked
um
so what happened yesterday i
it's totally good advice
which has um led to
forgive me but um
formal consultation with staff
is to our new field goals which is
i'm so emotional about this
it's the oldest train
to what to watch and to think what
potentially
awful of there's a face and it's so
destroyed
so big fine i can't tell you
it's the worst day i've ever had
just to sit and to speak to staff who
don't what they've done they've
committed themselves
and they've been through so much
and to then sit there and talk to them
about potential
redundancy or potential sale is just
something else
to be told this it's a massive kick in
the gut
summer has been like fighting mode we've
had enough naren
it is so uncertain we don't know what's
going to happen at the minute
we really don't
can i just have a good word please
nicola richards managing director
do you think you'll be here in a year's
time honestly
no no
it's been nearly 12 months since that
interview
and more care homes have already closed
down in britain
so far this year than in the whole of
2019
38 members of staff at newfield care
home in sheffield
have been told that they could be next
can you just take me through what's
happened the last few days
so yesterday we were all brought into
into a large room
um by nicola and we was told
you know she delivered the news that
you know potentially that we would be
made redundant
it's it's really tough um i think we're
still
quite in shock and as soon as we had
that meeting i was
straight looking for another job because
i thought i can't be out of work
we've been put through it we've been put
through a lot since
it all started and then to be told this
it's a massive kick in the gut as if to
say
thanks for all your hard work kicking
out
to be in a position after fighting a
pandemic with my team
facing a closure is just
something else
it's just a stark reminder of the mess
that social care is in
we've heard empty promises for many many
years now
the country where the only way pensions
can get long-term care
is by selling their home this time also
to make public services
personal to the needs of the elderly the
labour government both at the start and
the end of its period in power made
promises
to reform social care but none of those
promises were acted on
i started writing letters to mps
and basically trying to lobby on behalf
of of our residents and our staff to
protect our services
4th of july 2011. as you will be aware
the fees being paid by most local
authorities
are insufficient due to the increasing
cost that providers have
and continue to face
in 2013 the coalition government
announces it'll overhaul
how care is paid for once the
conservatives won a majority in 2015
the then chancellor george osborne
announced the implementation would be
delayed
20th november 2015 it is a moral outrage
that the livelihoods of staff should be
put at risk
we are offering a long-term solution for
the sustainability of social care for
the future
in 2017 the conservatives say they'll
inject 2 billion pounds into social care
and speed up reforms we thought this is
it
this is it after all the years of of
campaigning
of raising the issues we were just
hopeful that finally
um the support would come the
conservatives win the election
but those reforms are delayed by one
year
then by two after 20 years of empty
political promises
by the end of 2017 social care reforms
grind to a halt
[Applause]
so i am announcing now on the steps
of downing street that we will fix
the crisis in social care once and for
all with a clear
plan we have prepared to give every
older person the dignity
and security they deserve
they're just words empty promises
it's fixed nothing
she's the last person at newfield
and there's nobody else here there's
just us and shirley
um
shirley scott fought coronavirus
and pulled through she first moved here
with her husband gordon
who passed away in december but the home
is closing and she's got to find
somewhere else to live
it seems very upsetting it's been crying
since
friday
because he like get like a family
and he hopes that we don't know where
we're going you see we can't get
we need it we need the information and
we're what's
vacant to us we don't know what's vacant
to us but they're expecting us to go but
we don't know where we're going what
impact does all that moving
have on you do you think well i've been
in a bit of a dream losing my husband
i don't care what happens to me really
but it's
as i said 85 in the marvelous
hunter i'm not gonna address
i need to find somewhere
she thought this worth forever home uh
we didn't think we'd be packing boxes
um to move shirley definitely didn't not
not
85. it'd be like this a week and we
new field is no different to thousands
of other homes across the country
and it's just sad that it's come to this
it's just sad
and very sad so
there's nothing we can do about it
everyone has been through so much here
you you know
it's all you were around and
it is just like you
put your life out and said i'm doing my
best i'm going to do my best
and then you are paid this way it's like
is that how life is and we're all in the
same boat i know we are we all
are and it's we just need some answers
need to know what's going to be
happening
i feel really deflated i feel like you
know
i feel like it's not happening you know
it's a bit surreal
um i just keep i keep hoping that
somebody might buy it
or you know something's going to happen
i've still got that up
that is what it is yeah
you can't do much about it you just keep
on going
and keep smiling
the home is put up for sale if a buyer
isn't found in three weeks
it'll close the staff now enter
discussions about redundancy
thank you for coming everybody for
giving up your time for today's meeting
so this is
the um second part of the consultation
process
um looking at you're representing the
employees it feels like an absolute
lifetime each week that we
you know that we don't know any more
information so it is really difficult
and i think
people are finding it really stressful
at the moment so we've got everybody's
feedback for this meeting today
okay we feel very let down and angry but
not just for us it's it's just in the
care sector in general
it doesn't just affect us it's everybody
the good thing is they they're all
on board and engaging and speaking to
everybody and i thought that they raised
some really good points
they're doing well they're doing an
amazing job you know
they're going through the process yet
they're talking to their own
teams about it and obviously there's a
lot of questions but some of them
just can't answer this time it's just
feels surreal really
we would be more protected if we did
work for the nhs and
we wouldn't be in this position and
and that is the big difference isn't it
that being in the private sector it's
it's it's just not the same at all
right now reforms seem a long way off
the department for health and social
care has acknowledged to us that there's
a need for a long-term solution
describing changes to social care as one
of the biggest challenges that our
society faces
[Music]
when we finally see a proposal for
social care reform i think there are
important uh
core parts of reform that must happen
the first is about people that need care
and support
we need to make sure that they are
helped and supported earlier in their
care
journey so their needs don't escalate
too high
the second is our workforce who need to
be recognized and rewarded much more
than they currently
are and thirdly providers who work in
the social care sector
they need to be sure that they'll have a
fair price for care
the day the staff of newfield have been
dreading
no one's come forward to save the home
and the staff know exactly what that
means
so first
he's just we've just got to try and
support each other the best we can
through this process
my first job ever in care and for me i
just wanted to change
things a really good care home with
really good staffing
is gone
a tough day
i don't think we'll be the first storm
to close i don't think we'll be the last
and it just feels like the elderly
and i just not protected anymore
[Music]
the residents that we look after it's
not just work
they're more like our family
we are with people through some of the
best moments and some of the worst
moments of their life
[Music]
we were great carers we had a good home
i say good it was amazing
but if the care sector fails
[Music]
who's going to look after you